going to make pizza i tend to go without
just to make sure he's he's okay what do
you do when you've got a two-year-old to
look after and protect
but it's becoming nearly impossible to
make ends meet
that's the dilemma facing rachel and
millions across the country amid record
energy bills and rising food prices
these are the decisions which add up to
a cost of living crisis on a night when
it's quiet he's asleep he's settled
i'm not sleeping very well because i'm
thinking right what what else
before winter starts can i cut down on
you know what's going to happen if i
can't afford to pay these bills
with the consumer price index the main
measure of inflation rising by nine
percent in the past year
everybody is feeling it and feeling it
everywhere
the main thing pushing up overall
inflation was household energy costs but
that's now filtering through elsewhere
consider the costs mounting here at this
dairy producer we are seeing energy
costs rising sharply i think it's up
over 200 this year alone and even more
if you take a longer period we're seeing
feed costs for our farmers up by 40
i've been in this industry for 20 years
i've never seen anything like it of
course
all companies will have to pass that on
to our customers and ultimately of
course it goes to the consumer
with the bank of england now warning
about a potential recession however this
is becoming the big political story the
big question what if anything will they
do about it and whilst he dithers
british households are slapped with an
extra 53 million pounds on their energy
bills every single day
meanwhile every single day north sea oil
and gas giants rake in 32 million pounds
in unexpected profit we're already
helping people with the cost of living
in any way that we can mr speaker but
the reason we the reason we can do that
is because we took the tough decisions
to get this country uh through kovid to
make sure that we came out of lockdown
in the way that was necessary and to
have a strong economy with robust with
robust employment growth at a dinner of
business leaders the chancellor gave a
strong signal there will be measures but
no detail on when or what
and i'm proud that under this government
it always pays to work
but right now
we also have a collective responsibility
to help the most vulnerable in our
society
and so as the situation evolves
our response
will evolve
i have always been clear we stand ready
to do more for a long time the treasury
has worked on the basis that all of this
stuff cost of living energy prices all
of that will abate next year and
normality whatever that means will soon
return but what if it doesn't what if
it's high prices not just this winter
but next year and maybe even the year
after as well what if they go up not
just to 10
but a lot higher than that
those are the questions they are now
beginning to ask here along with another
how tough will this get for british
households
consider io's situation she's a working
mum but the money she earns simply isn't
going far enough i'm practically topping
up every week
um
just a little bit here a little bit here
because you
you've allocated the money for something
else that you're now having to put back
on the gas electricity it's a bit
difficult there's so much you can do
with one income
it's been four decades since britain's
shoppers faced price rises this steep
in the 1970s inflation caused years of
misery will the 2020s be any different
honestly
no one knows
ed conway sky news